[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y rosa Pérez mateus está con
nosotros como todas las mañanas en
nuestro programa Rosa bienvenida viernes
de Halloween Rosa cómo se prepara para
esta festividad si le gusta o no normal
normal
de pequeña celebraba la castañada que
vendría a ser lo mismo pero nunca me he
disfrazado de pequeña Bueno vamos a ver
entonces si nos disfrazamos saliendo del
programa Rosa y abrimos esta revista de
prensa en Estados Unidos con un sondeo
del medio usa today de Cara a estas
elecciones de medio término en noviembre
exactamente Raúl y básicamente lo que
adelantó ayer este medio de comunicación
es que en una encuesta sin especificar
nombres de senadores de congresistas no
de Cara a las elecciones legislativas de
medio término una mayoría de los
estadounidenses se decantan por votar al
partido republicano frente a la
demócrata dice un cambio respecto a una
encuesta que realizó el mismo medio en
de Julio cuando los demócratas lideraban
las encuestas vamos a ver entonces qué
pasa y continuamos en Estados Unidos
pero nos vamos a entrar en la temática
de Halloween como lo estábamos hablando
al abrir esta revista de prensa el
artículo como vivir con un fantasma de
Ana Conde para el New York Times
exactamente es un artículo sorprendente
interesante todo a partes iguales que
hemos decidido pues destacar y comentar
hoy con bastante grado de detalle este
artículo empieza con una historia
personal particularmente la de Shane
Boot un profesor de fotografía de 45
años que vive en Benson Carolina del
Norte y dice una tarde cualquiera bus
estaba doblando ropa en su habitación
cuando lo sorprendió un ruido muy fuerte
salió de su habitación y encontró una
ventana rota y su perro sentado afuera
estaba desconcertado cómo pudo a su
perro haber saltado por la ventana con
la fuerza suficiente para romperla Pero
esto no acaba aquí dice el Señor Buzz
limpió el vidrio y al regresar a su
habitación
toda la ropa que había estado doblando
esparcida por la sala y allí pensó esto
da realmente mucho miedo después en el
artículo el señor Buzz así como otras
fuentes citan otros sucesos no cuadros
que estaban Colgando colgados en la
pared que los encuentran puestos
tranquilamente digamos Sin daños en el
suelo es decir que no Podrían haber
caído por su propio peso jarrones que se
mueven también dice que oyó risas en la
casa sin que hubiera Aparentemente nadie
y de hecho que llegó a ver a un fantasma
de un hombre mayor y según el texto Rosa
el hecho que esta casa está encantada se
ha convertido digamos en toda una
atracción comercial para el negocio
inmobiliario exactamente y además Raúl
es que el caso del señor Wood no es un
caso aislado sino muy lejos digamos de
la realidad y es que cada vez más
estadounidenses creen que su hogar está
habitado por fantasmas particularmente
un estudio de octubre de la empresa de
seguridad vivint descubrió que casi la
mitad mil propietarios encuestados
creían que su casa estaba encantada otra
encuesta a mil personas realizada por
realstate Witch encontró resultados
similares con el 44% de los preguntados
que declararon haber vivido o vivir en
una casa embrujada y respecto a lo que
comentabas no que se ha convertido ya en
un elemento digamos de marketing de
atracción para el negocio inmobiliario
nos dan los siguientes los siguientes
datos Y es que en 2021 una propiedad de
Massachusetts escenario de los
asesinatos de la familia borden se
vendió por
1.875 millones por encima del precio de
Mercado no Y esto es el caso también de
otras propiedades que menciona el
artículo pero es que nervio Andy también
se encuentran decenas de anuncios que
como reclamo publicitario pues ponen
descripciones como Oasis embrujado en el
segundo piso o una guarida de fantasmas
y de hecho la cuestión llega hasta el
punto que en Nueva York o en Nueva
Jersey
propietarios a la hora de vender una
propiedad tienen que declarar a los
compradores si han registrado algún tipo
de Actividad Paranormal me daría miedo
meterme en una casa ha sido alquilar una
airbnbía hacia ti Rosa Sí también
este aumento de una creencia en
atracción Paranormal bien básicamente a
tres factores resumidos en este artículo
por un lado la pandemia dice que pasamos
a raíz de los confinamientos más tiempo
en nuestras casas por lo que tanto
podemos ser más sensibles a percibir
fenómenos paranormales como a fenómenos
normales como por ejemplo el ruido de la
madera que se contrae o se dilata en
función de si hace más frío o más calor
y además vivimos muchas muertes
repentinas no sin un último contacto sin
un último adiós por lo que muchas
personas quisieron contactar con
personas cercanas fallecidas con estando
digamos con un en el más allá no lo que
se llamaría por otro lado dice También
hay una importante caída de las
creencias religiosas no según una
encuesta del centro de investigación piu
de 2021 el 30% de los estadounidenses no
tienen afiliación religiosa lo que es un
10% más que hace una década y dicen
después de todo el mismo Consuelo
comprensión que la religión pueda
brindar a las personas también se puede
encontrar en las creencias Y por último
no dicen los jóvenes son más propensos a
las personas mayores en creer en
fenómenos paranormales porque están muy
en contacto con toda este mundo a través
de tiktok de series o de documentales En
plataformas no y básicamente dicen que
este mundo brinda un sentido charol Hill
investigadora de cultura Paranormal dice
para los más jóvenes si el mundo moderno
no nos alimenta el alma si el
capitalismo nos priva de la iluminación
personal Es normal que busquemos eso en
otros mundos rápidamente cerramos una
portada de New York exactamente que
también la dedica a esta festividad con
el título old hands una portada de
Sergio García Sánchez que vendría a ser
complejos fantasmas que llegan a esta
estación no tan mítica de Gran central
de Nueva York Rosa como siempre
muchísimas gracias y bueno fin de semana
de brujas a ver si se termina
disfrazando Rosa hasta el lunes Gracias
por toda la información y nosotros
saludamos a nuestro primer invitado